The postmodernists,
they're the,
they're the logical conclusion of the
Nietzschean dilemma.
God is dead value.
The value structure collapsed.
The specter of rises of all value
structures collapsing.
That's the postmodernist dogma.
All value structures have collapsed.
They're only there for the purposes of
exclusion.
They have no intrinsic value.
It's a very,
very powerful argument.
That's why it dominates the
universities.
That and the fact that allows people to
dispense with their moral
responsibility,
which is something that's never
discussed by the postmodernist,
but you have to give the devil his due.
What's the problem with postmodernism?
Well,
if all value structures have collapsed,
then there's nothing to do because in
order to do something,
one thing has to be better than another
because otherwise why do it?
And so people who are ensconced in the
postmodern tradition are undermined by
their own philosophy.
They can deconstruct their own
deconstruction,
in which case they might as well just
sit there and do nothing which would
actually be preferable to what they're
doing now.
So how do they extract themselves from
that dilemma?
They do any illogically,
but they don't care because the
postmodernists first of all,
don't believe in logic.
That's a reflection of the logos which
they've dispensed with dialogue.
They don't believe that because that's a
reflection of the logos which they've
dispensed with logic and dialogue are
irrelevant.
Well,
that does bring up the problem of what
to do.
Well,
the postmodernist finesse that by
reverting to the Marxist doctrines from
which postmodernism emerged and so they
say,
well,
yeah,
you can't get any direction from
postmodernism,
but we don't.
We're not going to worry about that
because we don't worry about such
things.
What we'll do is just use slight of hand
to push forward the communitarian
doctrines out of which our original
hypothesis emerged and everyone says,
well,
we'll turn a blind eye to the paradox
because we actually need something to
do,
and plus to the degree that we're
communitarian,
we can take out our nihilistic
resentment and arrogance and in
gratitude on every single person we
deemed to have something more than we
have.
And so if you're wondering why certain
values can exist in the absence of any
value,
you have to look no farther than to
understand that people who are desperate
and chaotic will still be angry and
destructive,
and they can manifest that perfectly
with the moral mask that says,
well,
I'm not really after what you have
because you have a little more than me.
I'm speaking on behalf of these people
who have even less.
It's like it's absolute nonsense.
It's so funny watching Yale students
complain about the privileged.
They're in the top one 10th of 100 of a
percent of people who've lived in the
entire history of the planet,
much less just the people that are on
the planet.
Now they're dominating patriarchs in
training,
right there,
baby representatives of the patriarchy,
and all they do is complain about that
tiny,
infinitesimal fraction of people who
have slightly more than they have now.
It's appalling.
And their idiot professors pat them on
the back and send them out the world to
do that.
Instead of teaching them how to live,
they damaged their mental health.
They,
they,
they heard our society.
They're bringing things down and that's
what they're aiming at.
The postmodernist managed to be
nihilistic and totalitarian at the same
time,
which is something that not even need to
dreamed about despite the fact that he
had the greatest imagination for
pathology that perhaps ever existed.
In addition,
they combine the nihilism and
totalitarianism with the worst aspects
of dogmatic religion because what
they've essentially established is a
cult into which children who attend
university are now indoctrinated at
great cost.
I might add,
and with very little practical outcome.